beaucoup restent à faire sur ce chantier
mais à cela ne régisse Luce a déjà
accompli sa part
les maisons individuelles de ostending
c'est le terrain de jeu privilégiés de
ce carreleur installé à son compte
depuis 2017 je peux quand même faire
deux maisons standard
en moi mon objectif
donc je veux toucher un peu partout il
s'est justement pour étendre ses
horizons qu'il accepte l'invitation de
la société Ozanam un bailleur social
réputé dans le milieu pour ses chantiers
difficiles aujourd'hui les portes sont
ouvertes à tous les acteurs locaux du
BTP pour une présentation des projets en
cours 20 logements à construire à
Fort-de-France 64 au lamentes en plus
des projets de réhabilitation au lourd
ou encore Rivière Salée à condition que
les chantiers trouvent preneurs que nous
avons mis sur les consultations et qui
sont restés infructueux c'est à dire que
nous avons pas eu de réponse voilà donc
c'est vraiment l'idée aujourd'hui de
pouvoir capter un maximum de réponses à
nos appels d'offres l'idée est de
pouvoir en fait présenter déjà
aujourd'hui notre programmation sur 2023
2024-2025 pour donner de la visibilité
puisque parfois certaines entreprises
peuvent se dire de ne pas répondre à nos
marché par manque de visibilité l'autre
difficulté majeure est administrative
car pour être éligible au marché il faut
aussi montrer patte blanche être à jour
de ses cotisations de sécurité sociale
or la majorité des 160 entreprises
locales sont des petites structures avec
parfois un seul employé aujourd'hui à
slam et plusieurs autres repartent avec
la volonté de tenter leur chance